for his welfare reform for the New York
Times he profiles its impact on the
lives of three women in Milwaukee in his
new book American dream this talk from
politics and prose bookstore in
Washington DC is an hour I really admire
the work that jason has been doing these
years and I admire this book immensely
Jason gave I think many of you know that
he reports on poverty in welfare for the
New York Times and that he's an alumnus
of the Washington Monthly where Charlie
Peterson ran the the the the magazine
for so many years and produced so many
writers of note the he we have a review
tonight from the Los Angeles Times I
just came out today which is a glowing
review of jason's book i guess it's the
first public review and so I want to
just read a little teeny piece from that
when I am i picking me up oh that would
be terrible the both camp in the camps
the pro-reform welfare reform camp and
the and the and the one that did was not
so enthusiastic about the welfare reform
read evidence selectively jason de
perles new book american dream three
women 10 kids and a nation strive to end
welfare offers a powerful bracing
antidote a reporter who has long covered
poverty for the New York Times DeParle
tracks in masterful details the effect
of the 1996 legislation on three
Milwaukee families as well as the laws
journey from Capitol Hill
and the White House to the state offices
and streets of Wisconsin he identifies
himself as a skeptic about the lost
merits at the outset but he weaves in
stories and statistics that don't
support his preconceptions if it's hard
to if it if it's hard to say at one end
whether well form welfare reform can be
judged the success that's because he
refuses to be one-sided that's a great
review its congratulations it's the
review that anybody would dream about
it's really a pleasure to have Jason
deparle here tonight to introduce his
book Thank You Carlin thank you for this
gem of a bookstore I live about a mile
away and stop in here about twice a week
just just to get a hug from the ambiance
before I went to when I was a very young
reporter of long before i went to the
new york times i saw the film eleni
maybe some of you have seen it's about a
new york times reporter getting his
dream assignment and in this case it was
the Athens bureaus Nicolas Cage he went
in and had to sell his boss on sending
into Athens to report for the new york
times i saw that it had a common
mystical appeal to me cop imagine doing
that someday for the new york times and
in the course of writing this book i had
my own cinematic moment where in my case
i want to go to milwaukee in report for
the new york times i had to go so my
boss on the idea he initially was a
little skeptical about the idea of
spending a year or more of human
resource time on the welfare system in
milwaukee if we're going to do it he
thought we should do it more somewhere
in our readership area and we had long
conversation I sold them convinced him
that history was being made in Milwaukee
and it was worth it worth the effort so
he walked me out of his office and he
put his hand on my shoulder he said you
know I've been to Milwaukee
guy this is my Nicholas Cage moment he's
gonna he's gonna say and I know you're
gonna make Midwestern friends and be
imbued in values that will be with you
the rest of your life or that he was
gonna say whether he was gonna say I've
been to Milwaukee I know this story is
gonna challenge you and make you grow in
ways that you've never had to grow
before but instead you put his arm
around me and he said I've been to
Milwaukee so I know your motives are
pure it's not like you're trying to go
to Honolulu the book is called American
Dream and it takes its title from an
obscure line in a Clinton Clinton's
first welfare speech in 1993 when he
first became president he said I think
we all know in our heart of hearts that
too many people grow up and never get a
shot at the American dream the book
tries to look at why that is and whether
this landmark change in the nation's
safety net helped or hurt in the 1990s
it starts in October 1990-1991 with too
coincidental and ultimately colliding
events the first is that Clinton in 1991
first gave his first welfare speech the
first time that he used the words end
welfare as we know it the second thing
that happened in October 1991 is that
two women Angela Jobe and jewelry got on
a bus in Chicago and went to milwaukee
in order to get on welfare is is the
Micro cut its mark turned it down too
much I think it's getting too much
feedback because you're too close to it
ok that is that better okay so Angela
job and jewelry get on the bus and go to
Milwaukee just as bill clinton's
promising to end Milwaukee and Milwaukee
becomes the place in the country that
becomes the first place where the roles
come down it's the sort of end welfare
capital of the country so eventually the
two stories come together and Angela and
and jewel leave the roles they both
become full-time steady workers once
they when they got up in Milwaukee a
third they they brought up a third
friend from Chicago a woman named opal
so the story is about three women the
opal Angie and jewel their lives on
welfare and what happened to them
the new law passed and they got off
Angie and jewel became full-time steady
workers the third woman opal was a
addicted to crack cocaine although I
didn't know when I first met her and she
she had a sadder story then I probably
would have guessed as possible before I
started writing the book there's a bunch
of elements in the book that we won't
have time to talk about tonight but I'll
mention them briefly one is the hitch
the families sort of three women are
cousins and I got variants in their
family history it began when Jules
mother the sort of matriarch of the
family came to visit her in Milwaukee
and I asked what I thought was a
perfunctory question you know mrs.
Crenshaw tell me where you're from and
she looked at me and said with a kind of
pregnant pause well Jason i was born on
senator Jimmy saloons plantation in 1937
that was back when black people's was
just beginning to come out of slavery
was a hell wow I was born in Bridgeport
Connecticut and you know what do you say
to that wish the name James Easton will
mean a lot to a few of you and probably
nothing too many of you eastland was one
of the last great segregationist of the
South was chairman of the Senate
Judiciary Committee for 22 years and
used to walk around with vice and he had
a pocket in his vest were all the civil
rights bills went to die and so one of
the things i was wondering is was james
isla just a name that she had her did
she really know him in fact it was all
true she was born and raised on the
Eastland plantation and there were still
people in her family living on the
Eastland plantation it was still in the
Eastland family I went down in the
summer of 2000 and that her 85 year old
great-uncle who was there the day that
James Eastlands father brought his
father drove them across Mississippian
and put him on the installed there as
sharecroppers on the plantation it's not
just an interesting story backdrop to
eventually I traced their family history
back to slavery through sharecropping on
the easel implantation up to Chicago
where they moved and then to Milwaukee
it's not just an interesting yarn it's I
think of vital context for understanding
what happened to them under welfare what
happened to them off of welfare which is
that much of the behavior that was
blamed on
fair non-marital out-of-wedlock child
bearing poverty the concept of
dependency black-on-black violence even
substance abuse trading in illegal
substances all these things were going
on on the eastland plantation during
sharecropping long before there was ever
a welfare system Newt Gingrich when he
was promising to end welfare used to
talk about how we couldn't sustain
civilization with 12 year olds having
babies which always seemed like a piece
of Gingrich hyperbole Hattie Mae is the
only person I've ever met who got
pregnant at 12 she had her first baby at
13 long before there was no couldn't be
blamed on welfare because of welfare
didn't exist so I'm not by the way the
first person to come to that insight
Nicholas lemon wrote about it 20 years
ago in the Atlantic and in this
wonderful book the promised land but I
think it was a context that was largely
left out of the the welfare debate in
Washington there's also a part of the
book about the privatized social welfare
system in in Milwaukee they took the
city and divided into six districts with
five different private providers in
there opal was the last one left on
welfare of the trio she was pregnant and
living in a crack house at one point her
case workers had no idea that she was
either pregnant or living in the crack
house they were sending her the money
there to buy the crack they actually did
a home visit there and didn't figure out
it was a crack visit a crack house but
they did spend several million dollars
on corporate advertising out of welfare
funds they bought they bought Maximus
golf balls Maximus but the name the
company was maximum it's a private
company at rate actually trades on the
New York Stock Exchange they had the
contract to provide the services and
they took several million dollars and
diverted it into corporate promotions
there were case workers in the office
who were soliciting sex from the clients
there were case workers who are
demanding kickbacks in exchange for
providing the benefits so it it wasn't
the most confidence inspiring example of
privatization but it did win an award
from Harvard and the Ford Foundation as
the best welfare program in the country
let me just say two short things about
why I wrote the book one well probably
the most the first reason was to satisfy
my own curiosity which is probably why
reporters take on any subject I was just
very interested in knowing what would
happen with this gamble with so many
millions of people's lives the public
purpose was I was hoping to build a new
constituency for people who would care
about the issues so they bring more
people into the welfare conversation and
within the conversation itself I felt
like it was very skewed by a polemical
tone I'm most of policy conversation in
Washington these days is overly
polemical and there's probably few
subjects that are more polemical than
them welfare so I do say at the
beginning of the book as Carla mentioned
that I was skeptical about the abolition
of welfare and the substitution of this
new system but i made as as concerted
and effort as i could to try to put my
biases aside when I went out to report
on it for the x and 2 in the hopes that
would be pleasantly surprised and in
some ways I was so I tried to I tried to
both to challenge my own biases in the
reporting in in the writing mostly I
want to talk tonight about Angie who's
the main character of the book and let
me as a way of introducing you to her
read read read a low passage about her
the month bill clinton announced he was
running for president she stepped off a
Greyhound bus in Milwaukee to start a
new life she was 25 years old and
arrived from Chicago towing two large
duffel bags and three young kids Angie
had a pretty milk chocolate face on a
fireplug build her four foot eleven
frame carried 150 pounds and the
combination could make her look tender
or tough depending on her mood she had
never seen milwaukee before and
pronounced herself unimpressed why they
got all these old ass houses she growls
where the brick at irreverence was
Angie's religion she repped arrived in
Milwaukee as she moved through the world
a short stout fountain of exclamation
points half of them capping sentences
that would peel paint from bus station
walls absent her animating humor the
transcript may sound off-putting
but up close for habit of excitable
swearing came off as something akin to
charm I just expressed myself so
accurately she laughed the cascade of
off the cascade of off color commentary
flowing alongside the late-night cans of
colt 45 could make angie seem like a
jaded veteran of get of life certainly
she had plenty to feel jaded about she
grew up on the borders of Chicago's
gangland her father was a drunk she had
her first baby at 17 dropped out of high
school and had two more in quick
succession she didn't have a diploma or
a job and the man she loved was in jail
by the time she arrived in Milwaukee
she'd been on welfare for nearly eight
years the sum of her adult life her hard
face was real but also a mask her mother
had worked two jobs to send her to
parochial school and though Angie tried
to hide it she still bore traces of the
English student from aquinas high lots
of women came to milwaukee looking for
welfare checks not many then felt a need
to start up home about their efforts to
discern God's will I'm tired of trying
to understand what God wants of me
worried that was too irreverent Angie
sub substituted the world the words
world for God and stored the unfinished
page in a bag so high in her closet she
couldn't reach it with a chair stories
of street fights she was happy to share
but the bag was so private that hardly
anyone knew it existed don't you know I
like looking means she said one day if
people think you're nice they'll take
your kindness for weakness that's a side
of me I don't want anybody to see she
didn't want me to see it either for many
years I didn't find the bag or she also
kept a secret journal that eventually
she opened up to sharing and it made me
actually I'll rewrite an entire chapter
about her childhood in which I had asked
her a dozen times what it was like to
get pregnant as a teenager and she
repeatedly said it was no big deal and I
would road out of passage that made her
seem sort of unthinking and how could
you get pregnant high school huh and I
really was struggling with because my
experience of her on the page wasn't my
experience of her in person finally she
showed me the journal and what she wrote
in the journal was I have a no I'm going
to have to change my life I have a life
within me
so it's just the opposite of what she
had said about not thinking and not
caring not not not having a reflective
consciousness about this life-altering
event I'm the fast forward she gets off
the I thought the bulk of the book was
going to be the process of somebody
getting off welfare and it'd be a huge
back and forth between the caseworker
and the recipient Angie had been on
welfare for 12 years by the time she got
off and she got Wednesday passed into
the new rules which essentially meant
she had to go to a work site in order to
get her job she left the roles in four
months so why would I work for welfare
when I could work and get a check I mean
work from get regular paycheck she had
12 years on welfare no high school
education by anybody's definition she
was a long-term hard to serve case and
she was just off the Roll so what I
thought would be the bulk of the book
was actually a kind of a non-event event
I mean it's it's significant but it
doesn't take too long to explain it in
the book much of the book became then
about her post welfare experience and on
a number of levels the economics of it
what it meant to her personally what it
meant to her kids what it meant to her
personally was act is a positive a
surprisingly positive story and she
became a nursing aide and I don't know
if anybody here understands was nursing
I didn't know much about what nursing
aides to shorten a nursing home it's
really a dangerous rough job nursing
aides get injured more often than coal
miners which is a kind of hard stats I
had to keep calling back pls and saying
the bureau of labor statistics that they
work in the health care industry and one
in five lives in poverty and there's
lots of scatological humor about it in
welfare offices about the bedpans and
that kind of thing lots of people leave
welfare to go become these nursing aides
Angie loved the work she liked loved
everything about it she loved wit she
loved the cleanliness of the nursing
home compared to her house she liked the
teamwork of the patient care she loved
the patients particularly the the
nursing home rebels I think who reminded
her sort of of herself she loved the
uniform the pride of thinking of herself
as a nurse I think it she I
the thinking she had more patience for
her patients than she did for her kids
it brought out it tapped into an
empathetic streak in her which was
lovely to see really there's a one of my
favorite stories I like telling about
angie is Angie's african-american and
she worked in a nursing home where the
patients were mostly old white polish
ladies from his ethnic working-class
neighborhood on the near southside of
milwaukee one day angie was cleaning up
a woman who looked up at her and snapped
and said get your hands off me you you
know what and on the street Angie would
if that would have brought out she when
I pulled out a knife or something but in
in this context she just laughed at the
woman and said well do you know what is
cleaning because you can't do it
yourself and you might as well left me
and she just laughed it off and then I
asked about afterwards well old people
you can't they're not responsible for
what they say it just it brought out
this wonderful human connectedness and
when Clinton talked about the welfare
bill he talked about work establishes
meaning and dignity in life and it's one
of the building blocks of the way we
cover our society where we connect with
each other yeah I had to in Angie's case
at least see some truth in it less so in
jewel who's the other woman who gets off
but who who worked just as successfully
as Angie but but didn't it didn't mean
as much to her so on the meaning level i
would say Angie's experience was was a
large success on the money level it was
less so I'd say well it was sort of a
wash her earnings went way up her
welfare went way down she she might have
been ten percent better off after after
welfare than she was when she was on
welfare but there was so many other
things going on in her life on the way
described in the book is her progress
got lost in the noise of living I mean
it one year she might have been a little
bit off next year her her car might have
broken down and it wouldn't be any
different one thing that did surprise
that didn't surprise me so much know
what I knew about people who leave in
welfare what did surprise me it's just
how much economic hardship she suffered
as a successful worker Angie ranked in
about the top twenty percent of women
leaving the roles in Wisconsin and she
had her lost her lights three
times in as many years was out of food
more times than I can count she was too
proud to say it if you ever asked her
this was really hard to get as a report
if you asked her is food a problem in
your house ain't nobody going hungry
around here but you discovered a lot of
the fights in the house ultimately we're
about food it'd be nine o'clock at night
and and nobody would have eaten then
people would be having an argument a
fight would break out I found the food
problem actually be widespread far
beyond Angie jewel the second successful
worker who similarly earns about as much
as Angie so similarly in the top fifth
of the people on the welfare rolls lost
both Angie and jewel lost their health
insurance jewel was hospitalized with
bleeding ulcers and had her wages
garnished to pay the real way I found
the jewel hardly even Jill didn't bring
it up the way i founded out was she was
heating the house with with it with an
oven so I was said Ye husband oven and
it was because the month wages were
being she'd lost her heat and her weight
because we're a wages were being
garnished to pay the medical bill but
the saddest part of the story to me was
I looked at her with a probably a look
of astonishment and she said well
everybody who works I was a hospital
bill everybody who works is going to get
their wages garnished she was looking at
me as astonished by my surprises I was
looking at her but astonished that she
was getting her wages garnished I I
tried to say something when I talk about
the book I tried to say something based
on the conservative audience that both
they want to hear and don't want to hear
in the same to a liberal audience so I'm
talking to conservatives I try to say I
think you were right that people could
work more than then liberals understood
but I think you haven't fully grappled
with the thin rewards of work at the
bottom of the wage scale and just how
much economic hardship persists the
third part of Angie's life that I talk
about in the book and probably the most
important is what affect her work has on
the kids because some people would say
that okay by the time Angie's 30 years
old and she's been well for all these
years and she doesn't have a high school
degree it's yes she's going to have a
difficult life under any circumstances
but we really want
her experience is to set a role model
example have her become a role model for
kids we want to put the kids on a
different trajectory and this was the
place where I thought the script where
the reality most departed from the
script of the Washington conversation
there was so much talk in Washington
about working mothers being role models
for their kids that just by taking a
single mother and putting her into the
workforce was going to somehow change
the trajectory of family life and it's
an idea with intuitive appeal I want to
believe it I probably lots of people
here working parents they want to
believe it it just didn't hold true for
most of the single mothers I knew
raising kids in these economically
deprived conditions and dangerous
neighborhoods in Angie's house to give
you a little of the feel for it Angie
takes an opal the woman with a drug
problem and gets so opal and her four
kids so Angie's got a four bedroom house
with one bathroom Angie's got four kids
opals in there with four kids and opals
dating a drug dealer so there's a drug
dealer in the house he's selling drugs
out of the house all the kids of course
know he's selling drugs at another point
another one of Angie's friends moves
back to town she takes in her too she's
got four kids at there were 17 people
living in the house at one time with one
with one bathroom so Clinton Clinton
used to talk about you in work brings
social order it would they didn't hit
Angie's house and she also had her
boyfriend Mark had a boyfriend living
with her Marcus who the kids really
despised and while Angie there were
times when angie was away at work where
either the kids would be in a big fight
with Marcus and or other times Marcus
was smoking dope with the kids so rather
rather than setting a role model for her
kids by being at work sometimes she was
just away leaving them exposed to two
more hardships Clinton as president used
to always tell a story about role model
role model mothers he told the story of
a woman named Lily Hardin he must have
told this story 20 times as president if
the story is that when he was governor a
woman named Lily harden you know
Arkansas woman named Lily harden left
welfare and when he asked through went
through his welfare-to-work program left
welfare when he asked her what was the
best
thing about leaving welfare she said now
when my son goes to school and ask him
what does your dad do he can give an
answer and that was I think more than
anything the the idealistic hope for um
for changing the welfare system between
the time Clinton told that story as
governor and the time he repeated it 20
times as president that son went to jail
for shooting he's now about 30 years old
and has been arrested 20 times the last
ten years we can we called down the the
north little rock police station we're
trying to get his police records and
said we want to track down Carlton
hardens police records Gennie his date
of birth this oh no we got him no no
there might be more than one Carlton
harden let me give you is David oh no no
we know Carlton yep he's got a long
record here you sure you got enough Pat
fax paper I mean he was an infamous
arrestee in North Little Rock rather
than even as Clinton is still telling
the story about how his mother's shining
example it saved his life when I came
away from that social disarray thinking
about was the importance of fathers it
wasn't because I thought of it was
because the people talked about it so
often at every level every generation
Angie tells the story of becoming of
going of becoming a nursing aide by were
talking about her relationship with a
font her father he was a cheeky was an
alcoholic and she saw him for the last
time right before she moved to Milwaukee
and she hadn't seen him in several years
she didn't know how much he had declined
he died like a month Labour's last time
she saw him and she said she's felt
terribly guilty about not taking care of
him and thats what made her go into this
nursing home to take care of other
people there's actually ethnographies of
nursing home workers and say they're
primarily motivated by non-economic
rewards which might not be a surprise
given how little it pays but it people
are drawn to wanting to be caretakers
that's the target that's what becomes
them Angie used a lot so I had that
theory and back of my mind usually when
I floated my theories on Angie she would
look at me and then scrunch up her face
and it look like she was sucking a lemon
and tell me what a ridiculous idea it
was but this one she just volunteered it
was because
my daddy that's why I became a nursing
I'm Keisha her daughter her teenage
daughter when chooses a crosstown high
school with a pre-law program because
her father's in jail and she wants to
get her father how poor Keisha is not
she's a terrible student and she has
asthma and being taking a bus across
town was probably the last thing she
needed to do it just exacerbated her
absenteeism problems but she was telling
herself that she was going to become a
lawyer and get her dad out of jail red
who is Angie's oldest son has all kinds
of problems and they relate to his
father let me let me just read a short
passage here this is this is red when
he's in eighth grade as the years
progressed so did Reds problems he cuts
school he smoked a lot of weed like
keisha he found someone three years
older to date Angie worried that with
his streetwise air as he was trying to
emulate Greg that's his damn she also
worried that he didn't have the metal to
pull it off red is as sweet as pie but
wanna be bad she said raises a kitten
red as a baby he's a ticking time bomb
most of his teachers shared Angie's
fears and some just gave up on him but
at least one saw some promise calling
him artistic thorough when you want to
be and praising his sense of humor among
the papers that survived in the bottom
of his closet as a middle school essay
called a grimmer mouse this is the essay
he has small pointed ears and a big
round body I found him in the woods
crying in a box I came across it one day
and asked him why the moths had been
crying because he was just left out
there by himself red said somebody who
was supposed to be bathing them feeding
him Washington and stuff wasn't doing it
why not I asked probably because they
didn't have no money to feed him and
stuff how did that make him feel he was
crying because he was sad red suddenly
stopped and looked up until then he said
he hadn't realized that he'd been
writing about himself that's about my
daddy he said he wasn't here
everything in the house seemed about it
seemed to be about the missing father
really when he came down to it and in
the same at angie's generation the same
Reds grandmother also talked to me about
her own yearning for a father I was
asking the day whether I thought this
was a hopeful story and I actually do
for all the hardship involved in it I
came of age on the poverty beat at a
time when 20 about 20 years ago when
things were bad and getting worse by
every indication poverty was a wages
were down drug use was a crime was up in
worse than that I think the situation is
and the ground was a kind of futility in
the air if you remember Reagan Ronald
Reagan's quip we fought a war on poverty
and poverty one the the message there
was just it's hopeless to even bother go
run a bookstore um the entire field was
dispirited everybody in welfare policy
good these conferences every just felt
beaten down not just welfare but poverty
policy more broadly that changed in the
mid-90s and I think welfare was part of
the welfare bill was part of the change
but there were other things going on the
official poverty rate went down people
flooded into the workplace in record
numbers including Angie even though even
the policy story made some progress the
Earned Income Tax Credit grew awaits our
program of wage supplements grew so to
the point where its provides Angie with
45 thousand dollars a year there's the
right amounts of some health care for
for low-wage workers there's reason I
think I think to be to feel much more
confident now than then when I first
started writing about poverty I think of
these things for all the hardship left
in Angie's life as a what a diplomat
would call a confidence-building measure
it's a first step I think it's helped
dissipate any reason for cheap cynicism
about what we can or can't accomplish
I'm particularly in an election season
there's just no excuse not to feel like
we can get out and do something to help
low-income men the way we help
low-income women over
past 20 years I won't conclude with with
just a thought from the book about the
notion of entitlement which was at the
center of the welfare debated eight
years ago the welfare revolution grew
from the fear that the poor were mired
in a culture of entitlement stuck in a
swamp with excessive demands legal
prerogative social do there certainly
was a culture of entitlement in American
life but it was scarcely concentrated at
the bottom has anyone following the
waves of corporate scandals now knows
what really stands out about Angie and
jewel is how little they felt they were
owed they went through life of acting
entitled to nothing not heater lights
not medical care not even three daily
meals and they scarcely complained when
welfare was there for the taking they
got on the bus and took it when it
wasn't they made of the plans in ending
welfare the country took away their
single largest source of income they
didn't lobby or sue they didn't march or
riot they made their way against the
odds into wearying underpaid jobs and
that does now entitle them to something
to a shot at the American dream more
promising than the one they've received
I see there are a lot of standees in the
room and there are some chairs that
people if you could put up your hand if
you have a chair next to you that's free
and anybody who wants to stand anybody
wants to come in the front and sit down
is welcome too there's chairs over here
there's a chair here and there the other
thing if we have a microphone here we're
going to ask people to please use the
microphone to ask questions I think the
obvious question I'm going to start with
is what Jason would recommend
as a way of I mean it really infuriates
me how the country is so skewed away
from helping from compassion the
opposite of what George Bush promised
and I I but I do think and I'm glad that
Jason see some hope and I would like him
to talk some about what we would need to
do as a nation if we're going to fulfill
the American dream for the people he
writes about broadly speaking three
ideas for the women we're sort of
halfway down the road to building what
might be called a work based safety net
supplementing the life of a low-wage
workers so that they can live under less
economic hardship in terms of health
care for low-wage workers wage
supplements for low-wage workers the
childcare program that's not a story
with no progress it's a story with
incomplete progress and we certainly
need to do more there for the men we're
really not doing anything I mean this is
the story of this book is a story of a
social policy targeted only on one
gender and if anything comes out of the
stories of the families it said the kids
the women they want to reconnect with
the men both they need them in
economically to contribute to the to the
families and they need them socially I
mean these these kids want to bond with
their fathers and the fathers want to
bond with the kids I didn't really get a
chance to talk about that but I did not
feel at all that the stereotype of a
cavalier man the hit-and-run dad held
true when I talked to the gods the dads
they felt driven away from the women
more than they felt like they were
abandoning with the women driven away
because they didn't feel adequate that
they had enough money to support the
women driven away by the criminal
justice system driven away because the
woman's in a new relationship so there's
a yearning for a connection and I think
the fatherhood the men field is where
the women's field was 20 or 25 years ago
I mean that the idea of moving low-wage
women into jobs once seemed hopeless
there was no programs that showed it was
having any success and there were all
these barriers and they'd have childcare
didn't have skills and all that and
we've made tremendous progress in that
area so I don't see any reason at all to
think why we couldn't do something
similar for
for the men and the third so women men
in terms of the kids you know all my my
affluent friends when they talk about
their kids that they always talk about
their over scheduled lives Callie I go
from soccer to the pool to the this
group in that group what you just would
not believe how little there is in the
lives of Angie jewels and and those kids
they're there they're like floating
through their childhood childhoods is
just this big sea of boredom until they
hit this islands of dotted by islands of
violence and chaos I mean they're
they'll sit around all week and not do
anything and then it nan jeez how
somebody actually broke in and beat
somebody's to death with a car battery I
mean it's sort of their life as two
weeks of waiting around and then 1 10
minute bursts of utter violence so if
there's any way to get the kids out of
those homes into some kind of aftercare
pro the most encouraging policy
intervention in Milwaukee has been an
aftercare program after school care
program for males particularly made more
of a difference for males than four boys
them for girls and those homes just or
dangerous difficult places to be left
alone in and you know Keisha at one
point was 11 babysitting for three
younger siblings while angie was away at
work there needs to be more of a place
for those kids to go we won't take
questions unless you go to the mic the
mic is right there in the middle of the
room as i pointed out
you speak about the process of getting
to know these families did you embed
yourself with them stay with them for
stretches of time or did you as my wife
is here I would like to take that on
directly but it would be nice to know
how you learned about them also question
number two what's the relationship
between welfare in the healthcare system
and their access to these families to
health care
the process of getting to know them
somebody asked me today how how did I
get what what was the secret of getting
to know them I kind of fumbled the
question I thought about it a lot
afterwards I think the best advantage I
hadn't gained to know them was genuine
curiosity may I really wanted to know
what they thought of the world and what
was happening in their lives and I think
that probably work it's probably any
reporters best way of getting them know
somebody at any level station of life
for them I think they were particularly
unaccustomed to having anybody have an
interest in them I wrote a near a piece
that r in New York Times Magazine a
couple weeks ago about Jules boyfriend
who is one of the is the rare redemption
story in the story gets out of prison
and turns his life dramatically around
and he got six or seven letters and a
little bit of money not a lot actually
hoping he might get some more and then
he called me up afterwards and said it
was the best thing that happened to him
since the birth of his son he said he
just couldn't get over the idea that
somebody would would never didn't know
him would write him a letter he was he
was startled by by the notion that
somebody had so little affirmation in
his life I think that was probably true
of all the women they just didn't they
weren't used to people asking that
asking them what they thought about
things in terms of the connection
between welfare and health care I used
to have to go on to welfare in order to
get health coverage and already get get
health insurance theoretically the 96
law changed that so that you could get a
health insurance so that it and there
was another those expansion program for
people who weren't on welfare it's been
implemented extremely imperfectly one
slight digression on the question of
reporting technique this is where the
story we're reporting technique and
healthcare come together my wife who's a
healthcare policy expert came to visit
the families in Milwaukee and one of the
dramas at the time was I was waiting to
see whether Angie who didn't have health
care would understand how to apply for
this new brand new Wisconsin program
it's is this is sorta by the internal
reporter
good person so I wanted to see the
situation unfold without inserting
myself too much further in her life and
Nancy Ann came in and said oh here's how
you get badgercare you just go down the
office you fell the application is about
welfare in taxes do you think that the
Earned Income Tax Credit is a Blippar is
it helpful and are there other tax
measures that you think would be more
helpful oh it's beyond helpful it's
crucial yeah its twenty percent of
Angie's income between the state and the
federal credits earned income tax credit
is the dullest word for a program that's
ever been invented and that's probably
why it's successful because it's like
this secret that it's a 30 billion
dollar don't tell me whether it's a 30
billion dollar program that rains checks
on poor people and it's fifty percent
larger than welfare was at its height
and it draws no controversy because
people are working and because it's got
this dull name and earned income tax
credit so which what it translates into
it's every once a year Angie ghost gets
on the bus and goes to H&R Block and
walks away with a check for between
state and federal about five thousand
dollars so it's crucial turning her
income in terms of what else how much
how much what else could be done to
change it in terms of the tax credit she
pays a lot of payroll taxes and there's
visitor there's a good one of the
chapter starts with a quote for me Angie
she's looking at her paycheck if she
goes who the hell is FICA
they eat miles up high as you well know
there have been lots of debates or
fights about using an education as an
opportunity for people to continue
getting some sort of welfare payment as
they're getting ready for the next step
in their lives you haven't said anything
in your wish list of what could help
folks who are no longer on welfare get
ahead and I wonder what your thoughts
are about subsidies for education and
training and the great debates over
where that stands and the whole
continuum of support for folks who need
it I'm a probably depart from the
liberal standard liberal thinking on
this point there's no question that
education is the gateway to higher
earnings I'm not real enthusiastic or
real hopeful about the ability of people
to get it through welfare for several
reasons one most important which I just
don't think it particularly works when
Angie and jewel they were offered under
the old welfare system they were offered
the opportunity to go to school and they
hit they had flunked out of high school
they had failed to GED programs several
times they had no confidence in their
ability to go back to school and get a
GED that didn't want something was going
to take them a year or two they wanted
to make money so sending them back into
a classroom for them and I think from
lots and lots of women is only to
reinforce failure so I don't think it
particularly works with that population
I mean God knows people need education
before they get to welfare but by the
time you're on welfare most people not
everybody means some people come off
welfare and get PhDs it's but but at by
and large I don't think they're that
there are promising population I'd like
to see for upfront training before they
went to work I'd like to see some skills
upgrade built in after they become
workers with the notion that it will be
more targeted and they'll be more
serious about it once their workers
there's also an equity question about
providing higher education through the
welfare system which is you don't want
to be if you have two people who are say
to women who are working it in a
low-wage job at Burger King you don't
want to set up a system so that the one
who goes on welfare gets the education
and the other one can't you so for both
those reasons I
of some skepticism about it as a
large-scale solution maybe there are
ways to do some of it carefully
carefully targeted that would work how
did you find the women and why did you
choose them I found I met opal one of
the women in a welfare office in the
walking and it was she immediately
captivated me it was a practice job
interview session in which I think
they're supposed to be about 30 people
there and seven had shown up and one was
eating potato chips under the no eating
sign and one of them was drunk and they
work on Elena it was just a portrait of
anhui and the case worker who was
leading the class kept fretting i'm
really not trained for this i don't know
how to do this yeah and she called on a
woman in the back to come up into a
practice interview it was opal it would
really take Tom Wolfe to do justice to
opal walking across the room but she did
this kind of exaggerated pimp walk roll
across them just exaggerated flip
flopped into this chair like she just
couldn't be more contemptuous of having
to be there and then the caseworker said
tell me your name and she I'm opal
cables Oh tell me about yourself well
I'm ready to go to work and my childcare
won't be a problem she's just put on
this show and everything the potato chip
Peter woke up and the drunk woman you go
girl and opal did it for about 60
seconds then she said but I don't want a
job and I like being on welfare and then
she turned it back off and she kind of
pimp rolled back to her so I'm thought
well this woman bilingual this woman's
attention I went up to her afterwards
and started hanging around with I had no
idea she was she was a she was addicted
to drug actually I started she had a
little part-time job i started falling
around the hospital I didn't even notice
this till later because I wasn't
thinking about drug use at all let's
think about welfare she told me this
story about she been in a gang and she
cheated welfare and she'd done all these
things and she just she said like she
just didn't care what anybody thought
you know she was happy to tell truth but
in the course of telling me the story
said the one thing that she'd never
tried was drugs and I went to her house
and she had a no drug sign on her door
and there was a guy in there who didn't
really introduce himself he had a no
drug sign on his lapel so you know being
an investigative reporter from New York
Times I determined there were no drugs
in this house and opal was uh it was a
rehab building that everybody in the
house had been come out of out of rehab
and she was in the process of
backsliding within six or nine months
she was homeless and in a crack house
but so through opal I met her two
cousins Angie and Julie I thought the
book isn't about opal initially and she
kind of dropped out as she her problems
compounded hi Jason I have a two-part
question the first is what is welfare in
the book do you get into it all what a
definition of welfare maybe because I'm
it seems to me that 20 years ago welfare
was the term used for everything that
was wrong with America and i think they
met women on a DC but yet there seemed
to be no conception of other government
entitlement programs to persons but they
weren't one somehow and welfare the
second one is to what extent do you
think Americans attitudes toward people
on welfare correlate to attitudes about
race and the the conceptions that most
people on welfare are african-american
or others well those are two big
questions as appropriate as this is Jean
sudden the man who baptized me so he's a
lot he's allowed to ask the big meaning
question what is your right about what
is welfare is welfare is a term that
could be here's a okay here's a story
that gets booked to both your questions
team I have a cousin who has a husband
who used to work in a liquor store so I
called up one night and said I am
housing he asked me where I was up to us
a mom you know we're kind of story about
welfare he said ya had a couple in the
store the other day I said a couple of
what you know black guys in the liquor
store him welfare was black guys
welfare in the context of this debate is
a program called aid to families with
dependent children which was created by
franklin roosevelt in 1935 mostly to
serve widowed mothers mothers who had
been married and mostly to serve white
women this gave States a lot of power at
the hest of southern congressmen who
didn't want any subsidies going to black
women that would lure them out of the
field so we're careful it was carefully
circumscribed so that this program aid
to families with dependent children
would not lower field hands out of the
field eat at its height it spent about
25 billion dollars Medicare spends three
hundred billion social security in that
range as so in financial costs it was
low symbolically had a power because it
as you as my cousin and you were saying
is suggesting it it stood for 'every
that got blamed for everything I got
blamed for welfare became a shorthand
for everything we don't like about inner
city life and it was thoroughly in
interwoven with race now it's true that
at any given time the exact numbers of
blacks and whites on welfare was about
equal but if you look at the longer term
population black Americans accounted for
about seventy percent of the long-term
welfare population so I would argue that
it was primarily a black problem
primarily not exclusively if you think
about the long-term population I would
also get that's no surprise if you think
about the history of african-americans
in this country and the injustice ease
and the exclusion has been given them
it'd be no surprise that they wind up at
the bottom of the economic and social
ladder and that's why I grew so
interested in the family's story inch
was able to tracing it back through
history through sharecropping I mean we
tend to think of sharecropping sometimes
it's something misty from the 19th
century but it was Jules mother's life
she was born on to this plantation and
grew up picking cotton at a time when as
she put it she didn't say black people
were in slavery she said black people
were just beginning to come out of
slavery and that was such a profound
nuance because if you go back and read
southern history
that's what they're saying about 9th the
1930s they weren't it in slavery but
that was just hints of progress
beginning in Mississippi two percent of
the people in Mississippi could vote
black people in Mississippi could vote
when she was born so to me yes it was
largely an african-american problem
because race is such a profound American
problem Jason say a word about
nonprofits and all of the do-good
activities everybody in this room
volunteers in or contributes to churches
and day care centers and anti-poverty
efforts of some sort and yet I haven't
finished the book but they don't seem to
figure in the lives of Angie and Jewel
and and opal are they doing the wrong
things are they not enough what this may
be a place where trying to tell the
story of 15 million people through 3
million three million people can't be
ultimately it's something I wrestled
with the lie I want to find three people
who were broadly representative but
certainly I have known people who got
tremendous help from church efforts or
from a kind of private mentor
relationship you're right that it didn't
it doesn't figure in this book I think
it would have been a benefit if it did
just because as I was saying the kids
are so isolated that God knows they
could use a mentor like that there
needed to be more connectedness and and
there was there was just nothing for
them seem to be available ah nothing in
oh somebody else maters our boys club is
there any place that kids could go after
they lived on a street called brown
street which made national news a couple
years ago because a gang of God out of
20 kids some of them as young as 10
years old chase down an old neighborhood
man and beat him to death I mean they he
became a con Brown Street I was reading
foot through the New York Times was a
pull quote said Brown Street it was a
symbol like browser is a symbol of
depravity and it was that was so empty
that you tend to think of the ghettos as
teeming place
I mean the ghetto in milwaukee's is an
empty place it's a void so around the
block sort of after the bookends
recently there's been some habitat for
humanity people come in yes it can help
no there's not enough of it in part it's
a quirk of their particular circumstance
since you mentioned President Clinton
and his time in Arkansas i thought i'd
ask about what you think of the
possibility of a microloan program like
the grand main bank and bangladesh and
if you heard anything about that where
they extend very small loans for
self-employment two groups of very poor
people and encourage them to become
self-sufficient through self employment
I don't know enough about it in the
context of the United States to give you
an educated answer I can give you a sort
of instinctive answer I have I spent a
year living in a poor community in the
Philippines where the woman was
operating on a kind of microcredit
system there and it seemed to it
actually did seem to do some good there
I'm a little skeptical of of that in the
United States for several reasons the
parallel amounts that I think women like
Angie and jewel would want or need are
much larger and by their own admission
they have a lot of problems managing
money and the idea of doing a running
your own business is a very thats a hard
thing to do for the most talented of
people it seems like asking a lot of
them to be able to start your own
business um I again for some people
under some circumstances if you had the
right screening maybe maybe it could do
something I don't particularly it
doesn't resonate with me as being a
large-scale solution I've been struck by
how since the passage of welfare reform
the power of race related issues in
politics seems to be less I wonder if
you count that as one of the successes
of welfare reform and if so how you
think the different atmosphere that's
resulted effects
the prospects for progress from here on
out yeah thanks John that's a great
question that as Clinton was agonizing
over whether to sign this bill in the
summer of nineteen ninety-six has
political advisor Dick Morris went to
him and with some polling data of
perhaps questionable provenance but
arguing to him that by ending welfare he
would be setting the stage for a liberal
resurgence he would end the negativity
around welfare and race he would he
would he would improve race relations he
would get rid of the negative
stereotypes he would lay the groundwork
for confidence in government I think
Clinton deeply wanted to believe this
and did believe it genuine believed it I
think it was one of the reasons he
signed the bill that whatever the
imperfections in this piece of
legislation he was going to get that
particular note he said at the signing
ceremony now nobody can kick around poor
people anymore this is all of our
responsibilities I had a chance to talk
to him for the book I interview him for
the book and so I asked him about
precisely the point you're asking he
said his prophecy sort of half came true
that just as you say welfare isn't and
it's disappeared we're in the middle of
election season nobody said the words
welfare me it mean if you keep you and
I've been reporting on these issues for
a long time in 1994 even Ted Kennedy was
running workfare commercials I mean
everybody had to be anti welfare it's
just disappeared largely that's good
because its presence was a negative what
hasn't happened we've removed the
negative of the welfare bash and we
haven't substituted the positive of the
of the progressivism that Clinton had
called for right so I said well why
didn't we and he said cuz gal Gore lost
the White House and because terrorism
arose and I think you pushed domestic
and concerns off I pushed Clinton low on
that because okay well Bush ran is
compassionate conservative why didn't he
why didn't he follow through in a more
forceful way and Clinton Clinton
actually said something he said he
didn't think Bush was a racist the only
really racist thing he's done in his
life he said was that stuff about John
McCain and letting people spread rumors
that he was they had had a black baby
out of wedlock but he sort of dissipated
out so I'm still waiting and
being that the positive agenda follows
through thank you very much Jason I have
a lot of questions but i'm not going to
keep everybody here asking them i I just
I think the books of fantastic
contribution and I'm looking forward to
reading every word of it instead of just
the chapter headings and so on the
things that I use to get ready I am very
I think it's going to be provide us with
a great basis for future actions we will
Jason will be happy to sign books i want
to thank Jason I want to thank you all
for coming in spite of the dire weather
warnings I hope that you'll stay and
talk to Jason and had your book signed
if you can give us a hand with the
chairs we'd be very grateful thanks
Jason the call
jason DeParle is a senior writer for The
New York Times and a contributor to the
New York Times Magazine American Dream
is published by Viking an imprint of the
penguin group visit